Hi there. Welcome to my talk. My name is
Sanja and today I'm going to share with
you an experiment we did at our company
that's somewhat unusual and very
exciting.
It was a one-month initiative called
radical speed month where two-person
teams were given full autonomy to build
and ship projects. I built three
projects during this time. I will walk
you through them and we'll talk about
the outcomes and learnings for myself as
a designer as well as the system-wide
impact this experiment had.
I'll tell you a little bit about
Automattic first. We're the company
behind several products in the WordPress
ecosystem such as wordpress.com,
Jetpack, WooCommerce, as well as many
other brands like Tumblr, Beeper, and
many more.
We are around 1,400 people and we're
fully distributed which is
pretty interesting for also what what
I'm about to show you. We're fully
distributed distributed and asynchronous
which means that most of our work, our
thoughts, our concepts from the past
couple of decades are very well
documented.
I'm a product designer and I've spent
over a decade building software and
watching how teams build software. I've
worked for I've been at Automattic for 5
years now
on the Jetpack design team and in the
past I worked for several companies of
different sizes, different
types of products, and different team
organiza- configurations. So after all
these years
I've not only accumulated experience in
designing products, I also have a lot of
insight into team dynamics and
organizational structures within product
teams.
Over the years the the designer role has
morphed and evolved a lot. We we had We
still have all of these different types
of
of roles like web designers or UX
designers or interaction or product
designers. We've also used many
different tools from the Adobe suite to
Sketch to Figma
and many many others in addition to
those. And AI is a new tool.
It is definitely not built just for
designers. It's versatile so it can be
used by many other
um many different roles, but the
expectation is is the same for everyone.
It's that it will bring a speed.
And of course, this is why companies are
rushing to put it to use. But no matter
what role uses AI,
um this
velocity is going to look very different
in small teams like one to three people
that are building new products. Let's
say a zero to one product versus large
organizations that might have built
entire entire product ecosystems, that
have software that's anywhere between 5
and 20 years old and that have uh more
than a thousand or even thousands of
people.
Before I dive into the experiment, I
will tell you a little bit about what
preceded it in terms of how we use AI at
Automattic. We were encouraged to use
it, to learn it, and to experiment with
AI from the very beginning.
At first, we had access to tools and
courses.
Then the AI enablement
was initiated where every single
employee goes through a two-week course
designed specifically for their role.
This is completely immersive with
lectures and and focused hands-on time.
Very very helpful.
And over time as AI coding tools got
better, everyone was encouraged to get
comfortable with contributing in code.
And we can thank our systems and
operations team for setting up fantastic
security and processes as well as
documentation that's good enough that a
non-engineer such as myself can spin up
a working development environment. And
last but not least, an incredibly
helpful tool that I that I use every day
for research and planning is context AC.
It's an MCP server that gives AI tools
access to all of the knowledge and data
that we have documented over the years
that I previously mentioned.
So back to the experiment. About 2
months ago, we kicked off this project.
The instructions were to pause the
roadmap work for 30 days, pair with a
partner, and ship something real. We
were welcome to use AI, though it wasn't
a requirement. And of course, um
we couldn't all do this at once. We had
to do this in in stages, and we had
about a third of the company
participating in the first round. That's
around 500 people
that started around 794 projects in
these 30 days. One lucky circumstance
for me was that during this month, I was
also participating in this 2-week
in-person AI enablement course. So AI
tools played a huge role in what I was
able to deliver.
Um and
that's why I was building not one but
three different projects.
And when Radico Speedman started,
uh
I I had some knowledge of GitHub. I
would review PRs. I had played around
with cloud code.
But I had never until then actually
built and shipped something in code. And
I mean
at work. Like I've done a small hobby
project here and there, but that's
completely that was a completely
different experience. Uh I'm going to
share my personal journey of how my
skills and process and collaboration
style shifted over the over the course
of the 30 days.
And this will also give us insights into
how this change can be promoted and
implemented at the organizational level
for large companies.
So this is the story of the first
project I worked on and my first
contributions in code. As I mentioned at
the time uh Radical Speed Month was
starting, I was at the in-person A&E
enablement training. And over there we
did an as as part of the program we did
an exercise where as a group of four we
had uh
2 hours to build something together.
We were two designers that aren't super
comfortable in code, an engineer, and a
product lead. And we decided to build
this board game session manager. We had
a board game evening planned that night.
Uh so we wanted to create an app that's
that's used to create, view, and join,
and manage board game event sessions. Um
you can see what that looked like. This
is what we built in in 2 hours. We built
an app um
where
people can start and stop uh uh a
session, uh
see what games and spots are available,
and even chat with each other. And on
top of that we chose this 16-bit style
um illustration of our actual office
that uh people found especially
appealing.
The most interesting thing about this
project isn't what we built. It was how
we worked together and leveled up
together.
Uh at the very beginning we agreed that
we all want to uh contribute, and we
were very lucky that the engineer that
was uh in our group was really really
great at setting us up for success. So
she set up the project in GitHub, helped
us grap grasp some basic commands, and
helped us understand how Git works. I
worked with versioning in the past um
for
you know, in different situations, but
and I thought I understood Git, but
actually I didn't. I really needed
someone to to tell me how it works and
and what what are the best ways to to to
set up a project. We were sitting
together, we were testing out the app,
and we were building it
um together and dividing the work among
us. So, we were committing code to this
project.
And since this wasn't this
this app that we were building, it's not
related to any of
of our existing products, so there were
no risks involved, and our focus was on
learning, which was really really really
great. We
only used Cloud Code
for this purpose, and outside of that, I
think the only visual tool used was Nano
Banana to to create um
uh to create the office illustration.
And the biggest insight, I think, for me
from this project was that
if you're an engineer, the impact that
you have when you enable others may be
far greater than the impact of doing
more engineering yourself.
And for any this this is a great
learning for any role. It can be
um the same for engineering or design or
product. Keep in mind that when you're
working on a team with mixed abilities,
and if you're stronger in a specific
skill, make sure that you're helping and
enabling each other up, because now with
AI, we can all do a little bit um of the
work that's outside of our domain.
And this was the biggest learning for
me, uh that engineers
will need to become
enablers and teachers.
Moving on to the second project I worked
on, this was my main focus for the
radical speed month. I paired with an
engineer and um
a design operations person. And our
goal, our main goal, we we worked on
some design system projects together in
the past. And here our main goal was to
surface relevant and up-to-date design
system information to humans and AI
tools.
And this um
problem space is huge. Our design system
uh
that we use for our WordPress ecosystem
products is open source. It serves many
products internally and externally and
is always in flux.
So, the problem space was big. Uh we saw
a lot of opportunities. So, we decided
to divide and each person took on a
problem to tackle. And what I proposed
this design system status track tracker
um
the solution that I proposed raised
questions with the engineer around
performance, around maintenance, and if
we would be able to to build it in the
first place.
But I was kind of empowered by the
previous exercise. I was allowed to
experiment, so I decided to build the
full idea as a proof of concept
on my own. So, um the discovery portion
was three people, but the design and
build was just myself. And it took
around 2 and 1/2 weeks
to build this. And as I worked on it
piece by piece, especially uh when I
reached the point where I had actual
live component previews working, I was
really mind-blown at what I was able to
achieve. I moved through the project
without any um
without any restrictions in mind. Um
I was just trying to push the limits.
And um
the tracker was picking up links from
the GitHub repo, from Storybook, from
Figma, sorting them according to status,
tagging them with the correct library
names. Search worked perfectly, and I
was really excited about this product,
and I shared it with fellow designers. I
iterated a little bit based on the
feedback, but everyone was pretty
excited.
I built the prototype initially as a
start, and then I used Figma
only later in the process for some
visual fine-tuning. Some things that I
just couldn't explain to claw to claw
code, I
I wanted to deliver an image, and that
worked.
But the live project was was I was what
I was iterating on directly.
And the prototype was built within a
week, and then it took another week and
a half to rebuild it for some fixes, to
set up a hosting, and deploy it in our
internal platform as an internal tool,
as well as on an external public-facing
site with that that had a little bit of
a curated
um
data and information.
And delivering this
this product was a defining moment for
me, where I moved from a designer to a
design engineer.
This is of course enabled by AI, but
most of all, it was enabled by the fact
that I could own the entire process. We
were within the radical speed month, I
was allowed to experiment. I I I had the
agency
and made all of the necessary decisions.
In large organizations, this is very
hard to do,
but here I could just build whatever I
thought was um
was needed, and I didn't have to spend a
lot of time in negotiations and
handover.
And then that was 2 and 1/2 weeks, so I
kind of had 1 week left
Um a radical speed month, so I paired
with a fellow designer and here you'll
be able to see the incredible shift and
speed and process that happened. In only
6 days, we went from zero to uh through
the entire process to building an iOS
chat for WooCommerce merchants that um
allows them to answer shoppers in real
time, reply from their phone, or even
set up AI to answer the uh questions for
them.
And this is a fully working proof of
concept that includes authentication
through wordpress.com, includes a
Jetpack connection. If If you use
WordPress, you might know what that is.
Um
we also built a widget that inherits the
site theming
where the site visitors can actually ask
the questions, as well as the the fully
capable AI agent that scans the site for
information and answers visitors'
questions in real time, and also
discerns whether it can answer a
question or or not.
What was important here was that the
the alignment and the the ideation part
was fairly easy. It was fairly easy for
us two designers to align and shape the
features with because we always have the
users in mind. And on the process side,
um
what was interesting is that we started
the exploration as a cloud code project
folder where all of the chats and ideas
were recorded into a file system.
And I I noticed that that um
significantly uh sped up collaboration,
as well as build later. And we've uh
continued I've continued this practice
in my in my daily work.
Um the main artifact we worked on here
as well was the prototype. And that's
the biggest shift for our process
because normally we would start in Figma
and we would work in Figma until we
reach very high fidelity. But here
uh, we had uh, very good plan. Then we
um,
built the the
the prototype or the product and then we
went back into Figma
to just come back to it in a visual
sense to build a mood board and for some
UI fine-tuning.
And in only 30 days, my process that has
been similar for years has completely
shifted. And that was true for many
other people.
The first project showed me how the
engineer's role can be elevated from a
builder to an enabler. And this is a
skill that I believe will be crucial as
more and more
um,
people in other roles start working in
code.
The second one moved me from a designer
to a design engineer.
Um, and here I'm talking about being
able to push code to production in a
well-established large system that
requires serious onboarding and security
practices.
All of the company initiatives that I
described together gave me the space I
needed to experiment and find my own
process that works
within what we already have established
in the company. And and the third
project that I shared was just proof
that we've unlocked speeds because I
already had adjusted my process a little
bit, but then
we both leveled up together and had a
shared understanding on how we can apply
the tools so we could also easily meet
each other.
If you're in a large organization, try
to implement this
um even just at your team level.
Uh changing processes or tools in large
organizations requires shifting the
human behavior behind them. So, provide
your people with the access to the new
tools, find your enablers and champions,
create space for experimentation, and
and give them agency so that they can
break out of their habits and unlock the
speed that AI tools can bring.
Thank you.